we've come to expect that we have to
fight over what's taught in our schools
but that's really not the case when you
let parents get the kind of schooling
that they want for their own children it
lessens social conflict and allows
people very much like in religion in our
society to get what they want without
imposing it on their neighbors what is
that the absolute top of your school
reform list right at the top would be
non-refundable education tax credits tax
credits are basically a way of allowing
people to afford private schooling who
otherwise wouldn't be able to afford it
and they have an advantage over the
other common policy approach to that
vouchers which is that they tend to
bring with them a lot less regulation
anybody can get a tax credit for giving
money to a non-profit right there's
actually two different kinds the most
common kind of tax credit that exists
right now is a scholarship donation tax
credit so a business or an individual
says instead of giving my money to the
state through my taxes as I normally
would where it will go to the public
school system I can donate to up
non-profit scholarship fund that fun
then provides scholarships to low-income
families so they can afford my where
where has this been tried and what are
the results so far lots of states have
scholarship programs like this Florida
Arizona Pennsylvania Rhode Island Iowa
there's couple of others and there have
been very few studies of the academic
impacts but in every case they are
extremely popular and they are very fast
growing tax credit programs like this
are growing much faster about twice as
fast as voucher programs talk a little
bit about a social conflict over
government owned and operated schools
yeah well a lot of people have noticed
that we had we've had school wars in
this country since we've had public
schools the big fight over teaching of
evolution in the classroom sex education
school prayer and on and on and on and
this is typical we've come to expect
that we have to fight over what's taught
in our schools but that's really not the
case when you let parents get the kind
of schooling that they want for their
own children it lessens social conflict
and allows people very much like in
religion in our society to get what they
want without imposing it on their
neighbors what do you say to people
who are like yeah but then we'll have a
bunch of schools treat teaching
creationism and we won't be able to
compete intergalactically with the you
know a space race of aliens yeah the
irony here is that people who value the
teaching of science and evolution in the
classroom should be the first on board
for school choice because if you look at
the understanding by the general public
of the theory of evolution it is
incredibly poor and that's after 50 or
60 years of the theory of evolution
being the official curriculum in the
government school so what we have now is
not working as far as teaching science
get does school choice and whether it's
through vouchers or tax credits what
kind of religious questions separation
of religion and state decided post you
know the supreme court looked at this in
Zelman V Simmons Harris a case about an
ohio school voucher program in 2002 and
they found that there was no conflict
there was no government endorsement of
religion when the money was going to the
parents and it was only the parents who
were choosing a religious or a secular
school so it's the same effectively as
getting a pell grant and going to a
religious college or a student loan a
guarantee a government guaranteed
student loan and taking it to a private
college that's religious exactly there
is still an issue though with compulsion
a lot of states have these clauses in
their constitutions called compelled
support clauses that forbid the
government from compelling anyone to
support a religious institution so any
school system that funds religious
schools is compelling taxpayers to
support those schools and so you can
have a state constitutional violation
even though the Federal Constitution is
not a problem fortunately tax credits
avoid that because under a tax credit
program you're either spending your
money on yourself in which case it's not
the government's money or you're making
a private donation to a scholarship fund
and you get to choose a religious one or
a secular one so there's no compulsion
what's your best guess for when the
berlin wall of the school monopoly is
finally going to be torn down i think
within 5 to 10 years we're going to see
at least one state that has a pretty
substantial market in education outside
of the public school system i wouldn't
be surprised if it's florida because
that state has a tax credit program
that's now on schedule to grow
automatically
every year for the next five or six
years we'll a tax credit program save
money or increase educational outcomes
it'll do both in Florida there's been an
assessment of the fiscal impact of their
scholarship donation tax credit saves a
dollar 49 for every dollar it reduces
state revenue so it's a fifty percent
return on investment and it's increasing
the educational options to family so
it's doing both how do you answer the
the criticism that I'm sure is coming
which is that yeah but it drains money
from the public school system actually
per pupil spending in public schools
tends to stay about the same or increase
under school choice programs so per
pupil the system is as well off or
better off will the system as a whole
spend less money if it's educating fewer
kids yes but then that's pretty much
what you would expect why are teachers
always whenever people talk about school
choice suddenly the conversations seems
to shift from children to teachers
certainly I think we would like everyone
to do well by a system but obviously the
goal of an education system first and
foremost is to serve the kids and they
should be the center of it the reason
that teachers so often become the
central issue in school choice debates
is that they have one of the most
powerful and organized and largest lobby
groups the teachers unions in the
country Andrew Coulson Cato Institute
thank you very much it was a pleasure
you